[Musique]
et
je m'appelle alice philibert 3 nous
redonne pèlerins j'ai 61 ans je suis
marié j'ai deux enfants et un petit fils
et je suis médecin généraliste mais je
suis aussi 2005 mais des petits mots
d'un anthropologue
[Musique]
cette nouvelle forme de médecine a
centré sur l'humain
parce que je considère qu'il y a deux
parties dans la maladie il ya une partie
organique qui concerne la médecine qu'il
ya une partie qui concerne la personne
qui concerne le lien est le symbole est
donc c'est une démarche que j'ai eue au
point à partir de ma propre culture
pour m chaque personne au volant de sa
vie de son ministre et de sa santé elle
s'appelle zoothérapie ça qu'il s'agit
que la personne s'approprie sa capacité
à remettre en ordre ses émotions et son
histoire ses liens familiaux ces liens
sociaux parce qu'on est souvent malade
de son histoire je vous demande et je
pense c'est la persévérance
quand j'ai une idée et quand je veux
mais un projet en route je me dis qu'un
projet c'est fait pour arriver jusqu'au
bout et donc je le mène jusqu'au bout
une autre s'est peut-être d'être
authentique authentique c'est à dire que
je suis fidèle à ce que je me suis fixé
et je ne peux pas me renier
me contredire attendent encore et à
l'intolérance c'est compliqué
toutes nos épreuves que nous apporte des
leçons de vie et que à un moment donné
sa campagne souvent de souffrance un
moment donné il faut trouver cette leçon
de vie pour pouvoir la fille la
souffrance est avancé à d'autres choses
parce que notre vie est promise à de
très belles choses je me dis que la
terre et la maison et des humains c'est
ma famille donc ce voilà c'est terminé
[Musique]